how do I have lunch with a millionaire
you're not you have no value to provide
and a lot of times you do have to
provide them value in the form of money
to gain access you pay your way in to
artificially inflate your network the
level of people who are Beyond you who
are above you Leila and I were in this
Mastermind guy gets up there and he's
like I had a bad quarter we're doing
like three or four hundred thousand
dollars a month we don't really know
what we're doing we're just figuring
this stuff out she and I both when this
guy finished talking we can do this like
if that guy can do it we can do this and
so like those are the gifts that you get
from being around networks of people who
are doing more than you and so it's a
way to shortcut you getting into a
network of people who are Beyond you
find out the places they go courses they
buy you can find out the books they read
you can get introduced to the people in
their Network and so then it becomes a
multiplier effect you meet 100 people
and those are people have access to a
thousand and then from that point when
you want to solve a problem you can hit
up your new network because your poor
friends from high school don't want to
invest you have access to solutions that
they never will